also in downtown Summerlin the light the  world giving machine has returned now  this is really spectacular it's like a  vending machine but in Reverse so  instead of you purchasing something and  getting out of it you actually make  donations and give something back to  local charities like help of Southern  Nevada Three Square Catholic Charities  and many more in there you're giving  items that in need you're giving  services to people in the community who  need them golden Knight Keegan colossar  made the first contribution last year  the site in Summerlin raised over 700  thousand dollars from forty one thousand  generous donors what a cool thing